[Musique]
on peut conduire des heures sans jamais
croiser personne
des centaines de kilomètres de step et
des routes de poussière
des trucs moutons traverse à
l'improviste en quête de verdure car
plus on avance plus ces gens
[Musique]
nous roulons sans aucun itinéraire là où
le vent et le sable nous met ici c'est
le désert qui pousse et non les plantes
d'incroyables d'une en bordure des
villages celui dernière ce qui c est le
coup mais la vie est dure quelques
enfants et des fermiers surtout comme
igor qui a tout perdu on regrette
cette ville était une grande fierté il
le construit de ses propres mains pour
les cinquante vaches qui faisait vivre
sa famille
et white ra parada alloudi moby aki
discussions parrainées lui au total
quarante mille bêtes sont mortes de faim
ou de soif
emporté par la pire sécheresse de
l'histoire du territoire
nous sommes en république de kalmoukie
un pâturage autrefois uniques ou des
décennies d'agriculture abusive sous le
régime soviétique ont mené à l'érosion
presque totale du fonds une situation
déjà désastreuse qui est aujourd'hui
exacerbée par le réchauffement
climatique
au niveau de cet or les niveaux du qatar
ni vous dites oui stromboli tu vaux
période
est inhibée le ministre aurait dit
au ministre a été remis à douchapt ben
ali
[Musique]
j'ai envie de pleurer dit il or à
balancer
[Musique]
sa détresse résume celle de milliers de
personnes dans cette république la seule
bouddhiste de tout le continent européen
des fermes abandonnées entre les steps
sur la route qui mène à berhane un autre
bled qui se vident 100 kilomètres plus
loin l'hôpital n'est plus le centre
culturel est laissée aux cochons il
reste au moins sept écoles devant
laquelle un chameau montrent la guerre
c'est ici que rim 71 ans enseigne la
biologie sa passion depuis toujours la
kalmoukie dit elle est méconnaissable il
ya en ce moment où tu osisko d'arriver à
17 ans coincé
quand j'étais petit peu l'herbe mal et
aux hanches et aujourd'hui
voyez ce qui se passe dit rima en nous
amenant la fenêtre de sa classe d'où
elle voit les d'une poussée d'année en
année elle y amène régulièrement ses
élèves pour mesurer l'ampleur de ces
enjeux environnementaux qui force
désormais de tant de familles à l'exil
il y avait mille élèves autrefois dans
cette école il n'en reste que 70 cette
hausse touche lounge toyota
touch à 15 ans nous explique avoir déjà
fui son village natal parce qu'il a été
englouti par le sable elle craint que la
même chose arrive à belgrade
et c'est ce qui nous attend prévient
rima ça continue doha
cynthia ni coop les deux derniers open
il n'y a pas eu une seule goutte de
pluie de juin à septembre
pas une seule
et c'est sans compter qu'en moins de dix
ans la température moyenne a augmenté de
1,2 degré avec un tel climat il est
presque impossible de renverser la
tendance et bars et surtout la route aux
sables la désertification gruge
désormais 80% du territoire quel mot
book soit
c'est un cauchemar et un cercle vicieux
explique svetlana oulanova elle dirige
avec très peu de moyens toute une équipe
de scientifiques à l'institut de
recherche sur les sols arides dans la
capitale elista ce sont souvent eux qui
financent les travaux de leur poche et
elle prévient que le pire est à venir
car les réservoirs d'eau sont en train
de sécher le réchauffement climatique
dit elle accélère le processus est pas
ce problème
nous avons pu le constater à plusieurs
reprises en sillonnant la kalmoukie les
bassins se vide est ce qu'il reste d'eau
et beaucoup trop salée pour la
consommation l'oliveraie par camion est
rationnée dans plusieurs régions du
ghana
les gens non seulement commence à
comprendre l'effet du réchauffement ils
le vivent et en paye les conséquences
roche a les zones
on se croirait en arizona ou en oklahoma
dit encore un jeune fermier qui porte en
lui 400 ans de tradition kalmouke
et quelques exploits grand champion
national de la tonte des moutons il nous
guide ce soir sur ce qui était autrefois
un hack et cedhd doute s'il ne sera
d'assister quand le soleil se couche en
kalmoukie les gens prient pour que la
pluie tombe mais elle est rare même
cette hauteur
longueur est aussi un père de famille et
un citoyen déterminé à protéger son
territoire
la dégradation du sol trop le climat
aussi tout comme l'idée de voir ses
enfants quitter la région comme tant
d'autres le font aujourd'hui comme beast
ip
comme chez
lesquels mob 100 leur step c'est comme
du thé sans lady d une tradition sacrée
comme l'élevage des moutons aussi dure
soit il de nos jours
car chaque matin c'est la même routier
pronger se lève avec le soleil monte sur
sa moto et pour son troupeau là où il ya
du gazon et des plans et ce
par quoi ces dix ou même 20 km et en
raison de la sécheresse on ne peut plus
exploités toujours le même pâturages le
gouvernement a imposé des limites sur le
nombre de têtes de bétail les personnes
ne les respecte
pas pour eux comme y'a pas pire que la
nature nous parle d'iran gore
et ce qu'elle nous dit c'est que je vous
traite comme vous m'avez traité
des paroles sages qui traverse
tranquillement les steppes un village à
la fois là où il ya encore un espoir
[Musique]